my name is Shepard Dolman I'm a
researcher at the Smithsonian
Astrophysical Observatory and I am
trying to take the first picture of a
black hole using radio astronomical
techniques black holes are engines that
redistribute matter and energy on
galactic scales they are integral to the
large-scale structure of the universe
why we look in the sky and see what we
do there's all these different lines of
evidence that we think are very very
solid the black holes exist that explain
a lot of things in the universe when we
think about observing a black hole we're
really thinking about and a tightening
the news like focusing in as deeply as
we can on this exotic object
[Music]
the event horizon telescope project has
a very simply stated goal to make the
first image of a black hole of the event
horizon and to really see what it looks
like the magnifying power of a telescope
is directly related to its size the
bigger you can make the telescope the
more magnifying power you have and if
you want to take a picture of a black
hole which is the smallest object we
know of in the entire universe
you need the ultimate in magnifying
power so we do this by connecting
telescopes that already exist around the
world and we record data when this one's
looking at the black hole record data
when this one is looking the black hole
and then we bring those recordings
together and as the Earth rotates that
we can reconstruct an image using a
telescope that is just about the size of
the earth so the event horizon telescope
is designed to take the first image of
light just outside the event horizon it
hasn't yet been sucked in but it's
illuminating this silhouette a hundred
years ago
Einstein came up with this entirely new
theory of gravity fine Stein's equations
told us what shape and size that
silhouette should be we're really
pushing these theories we're asking is
there something else is there something
we don't understand I really would like
to feel that we did whatever we could to
answer one of the deepest questions in
the universe do black holes exist and
what do they look like
[Music]
you
[Music]